clark county coroner has now identified
at least two of the victims from
sunday's deadly plane crash in north las
vegas 82 year old donald stewart
goldberg and 76 year old carol ann
scanlan died sunday after two planes
collided in midair now we are still
waiting on the ids of the other two
people that were killed but family
members have identified another 47 year
old zach rainey he was on board with his
flight instructor victoria saha spoke
with rainey's family as they cope with
their enormous
grief as people driving by glance at
what's left of one of the planes
involved in sunday's crash there's a hat
here left by friends and family of zach
rainey as a reminder of a man who was
looking forward to getting his pilot's
license it's been more than 48 hours
since tara tidwell spoke to zach rainey
on what would be their last conversation
forever i was actually speaking with him
on the phone when he pulled up to flight
school
it was about 10 45 a.m and we were
discussing our plans to go to the ball
game rainey and tidwell were married for
14 years and share two young sons
tidwell describes rainey as a free
spirit a man who loved to give and
someone who couldn't wait to fly he was
really close to being done and being
able to fly on his own and he was
definitely having conversations with his
kids about taking them up and his
friends on sunday's class was supposed
to be one step closer to making his
dreams come true zach was afraid of
anything
he was fearless rainey was on board the
cessna with his instructor from airwork
las vegas a flight school near the north
las vegas airport when it collided with
a piper malibu coming in from idaho i
texted him and he didn't text me back
i got worried
i looked up the video and the news i
came by i found his car at the flight
school
so i knew
it was about the same time i got the
call from the coroner the piper malibu
was flown by 82 year old donald goldberg
his passenger 76 year old carol scanlon
crashed pictures of the piper malibu
match the tail numbers of pictures on
their social media victoria saha live
local now